こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
弟に呼び出されましたちょっと前に動画
出したと思うんですけども今年の夏から
僕の
弟がサポートとしてうちの会社に入って
くれて
正式に初めて株式会社っていうあのふざけ
たための会社があるんですけどもで社長
です僕のサポートということで家に入って
働き始めてま大体3ヶ月ぐらいが経ったん
ですけれどもなんか話したいことがあると
いうことで
えー
動画撮ってます
撮っていいですか
まあいいでしょうありがとうございます
また何も聞かされてないんでちょっと
何なんでしょうね1回お話を聞いてみたい
と思いますどうぞ
失礼しまーす
あー
似てるね
似てんのかな
顔に出てんけどなんかね見た目と
動きとかは似てるって言われてますああ
動きは確かによく聞くわずる社長の弟です
よろしくお願いしますよろしくお願いし
ますタケルですで今回ちょっとよ
呼び出させていただいたんですけどもあ
パンをかけたね
髪色いい感じですねありがとうとりあえず
3ヶ月か会社で働かせてもらった形になっ
てそうですねまだ火山の仕事の引き継ぎと
かっていうのは本格的に始まってないんだ
けどそうですね本来は経理関係のもんね
うちの
母ちゃんがやってた部分を引き継ぐために
入ったんですけどちょっと夏がバタバタし
すぎてて裏方というかスタッフ的な動きを
してもらってたんですけどそこがまだって
いう感じでしょはいそうですねでもこう3
ヶ月間
兄貴の周りにいさせてもらって初めに私に
返したっていう最初を見させてもらってま
ちょっと気になったというか聞いてみたい
なって思ったことは何点かあったんですか
してもらいました
なんかちょっと思い当たりをしてあります
か思い当たる
らしいまあさすがに年なんで
昔みたいに24時間フルカードと時にも
行かないですけどもそれなりに元気に仕事
やってるつもりではあるんですけどね
なるほどはいいやそれですうん
元気すぎるんじゃないかなっていう
ところがありまして
元気すぎるんじゃないか
本当にこの3ヶ月間ぐらい兄貴の動向を
見守らせてもらってるようなところがあっ
て本当にいつ休んでるのっていう
まあたまにスマブラすんの
息抜き
朝からこう
イベントごとに呼んでもらって
働いて稼働してそこからまた東京静岡間の
移動がありますみたいな感じでそうですね
で動画の撮影をしてでそのまま編集をして
あげてから
寝て
起きたらまた
東京に戻って
仕事をして
編集してみたいな生活がずっと続いてるま
あ確かにね
実際普通の仕事の3番の観光としてはその
1個で
仕事は終わりっていうぐらいの仕事をして
いると思うから
正直1日で2つの仕事をフルタイムでやっ
てるぐらいの感覚に思えたりしかもこう
通常の会社だったら
鍼灸完全にあると思うけど月何日休んで
ます
休みがこの日ですっていうのは
あんまりないかな何かしらは絶対やって
おりますねそうですよねはい
壊れますっていやいや弟や
壊れてるんです
俺最初誘ってもらった時の動画でも
ちょっと出てたけど
兄貴的にこう母さんがもし倒れたら
うちの会社はやばいみたいな言ってた
じゃんもちろんそれは
母さんもそうなんだけど一番やばいのは
兄貴なわけで兄貴が倒れたら
うちの会社というかもう本当に関わってる
人たちみんなはいもちろんあの全員解散と
いうことで
間違いなくはじめしゃーちょっと畑だっ
たりねケンスケとか弟だったり母ちゃんと
か基本的に僕の周りを助けてくれるために
言ってくれるわけなんでもちろん確かにね
なのでちょっともっと体をいたわって
もらった方が会社のため全体的にいい
っていうところはちょっとまず思ったのを
伝えたかったっていうことですただ1つ目
ですあまだある感じですなるほどそれに
関してくださいはい
非常にありがたいことになんですけども
まあYouTube以外にお仕事も
いただけておりましてバタバタしてるん
ですけども
休みたいですただやるべきことがあまりに
多すぎてメインチャンネルの更新すら
ちょっとままならない時があったりとかし
て色んなお仕事をもらえるまあ原点として
やっぱチャンネルが見られてるからって
いうのがあるんで僕的にはもうちょっと
動画出したいんですね
じゃあ
ならもうちょっと頑張りたいまであります
休んでる暇がないよなっていうところが
まあ1つ目ですなるほどまあいたわって
ください
できる限りでいてわかりますはいどうぞ
気づいたと思うけどさ
YouTube以外すごくないやばい
やばいやばい平気で23日ぶっ飛んだり
するじゃんなんかそれで動画の投稿頻度が
映っててさ
始めもうYouTubeやる気ないんじゃ
ないみたいに見られるのもちょっと
嫌だからすごい葛藤ですよねもうちょっと
人気が出ればいい感じですか
2つ目がはい
会社に関わることというか何ですか
はじめしゃちょーの畑ってあるじゃない
ですか見てる人も結構いらっしゃると思う
んですけど
[音楽]
率直に聞いてみたいなっていうのが1つ
あります
切り込むね
皆さん結構気になってる人気になってると
思いますね
僕も気になってます
本当にじゃあちょっといい機会でくれて
ありがとう素直に話させてもらうんです
けども当初はじめさんその畑
僕が作ったわけですよなんで作ったかって
いうと動画撮ってないそのプライベートの
時間が面白いじゃんだって俺たち動画回っ
てないのに今日キング牛丼とキングカレー
食ったかなっていう動画じゃない部分でも
面白かったからそれは本当軽い気持ちで
ちゃんとねしようと思ってまあ大福と
ただちがいて1人面白い人入れようぜって
て今平君をオーディションで入れたりして
集まって俺の動画を撮ってる以外の部分を
見せようっていうので始まったんですけど
思ったんですよねうまくいきました最初は
そうすごい勢いだってすごい勢いだった
いや何がおもろいっていういやいや
俺からするとやっぱ日常映してるだけだ
からって言いながらやっぱりあれもあれば
と大きなチャンネルになって200万人を
突破しましたとでもちろん見てくれる人が
あってのチャンネルだから俺以外の人にも
つく始めるわけよ
好きな人洋服が
自分が好きな人とかいろんな人がこう
ちょっとファンとか人気になって最終的に
畑の1本目の動画でも言ったんですけど
俺がいなくても成り立つチャンネルにした
いっていうのがありましてで編集とかも
色々教えつつメンバー増えたり減ったりて
形が変わってるけども
上手く今のところは俺なしでも動けるよう
なチャンネルにはなってはいるなとは思っ
てますけども
当時俺が理想としていた部分と違う部分と
しては
あれ俺いなくねっていうさっきの話に
ちょっと長いのかもしれない
忙しすぎて出れないとかこっちがあると
思います
[音楽]
痛いところ
なんですよでかいんよ出たいけどさ
そもそも今メインチャンネルのまともに出
せてないサブチャンネルもたまにゲーム
出せるとかその中で畑に出れるかって言わ
れると今の生活リズムというか仕事上もう
無理じゃん
毎日それこそ休みなんか働いているのに
そこに追加して
畑の出演してっていうのになってくると
本当に
難しいっていうのは
それはねちょっと作った時と大きく環境が
変わってたというか
本当にありがたいんですけどもこんなに
YouTube以外で活躍させて
いただけることになると思ってなくて昔は
畑に使えてた時間が今別のお仕事だったり
メインもほらいろんなYouTuberが
出てっぱ俺も頑張んなきゃっていう気持ち
ますし規模でも負けたくないわけよねと
いうことで結構メインにかける時間も増え
たりでなかなか時間が作れないなっていう
のが
正直な部分ですなるほどじゃやっぱりもう
ちょっと人気を落とすしかないっていう
僕のですか許してください
本当にちょっとそれはねはじめしゃちょー
の畑ってついてるんで初めてちょっとい
ないんだよね今現状畑だよね
どうしていきたい
知ってると思うけどさ
目標なんて動くタイプなんですよそうだね
マジで今がいいと思ったことを全力でやっ
てそれをクリアして順番に行くっていう
やつ
野望とかないんですよ
将来の展望とかだからこのメイン
チャンネルもどうしたいか俺何にもないし
わかんないなるほどねはじめしゃちょー2
もどうしたらいいかわかんないしはじめ
しゃちょーの畑も今俺がいなくてはじめ
しゃちょーて釣るとやっぱ違和感あると
思うしそれも正直俺はどうしていいか
わからない
めっちゃ適当だな本能と感性でここまで来
ちゃってる部分が
獣だね獣ですでも畑のみんなと一応
コミュニケーション取ってるんですよ
彼らも借りないなりに頑張っております僕
がいない中で
舵取りを
実際今も兄貴がチャンネルの方向性とか
どういう動画を出してくっていうのも正直
決めてない状態というかそうですね
[音楽]
どういう風に思っているのかなっていうの
がちょっと気になった
純粋な個人的なでもまあ今聞いた限りだと
やっぱり出たいっていう気持ちがあるけど
めちゃめちゃ忙しいから
正直難しいかなっていうところが
正直なところかなと思います
頑張ってるからさ
忙しいんよね彼らもスケジュールくんでる
じゃんしっかり昔の畑ってもう本当に必要
でスケジュールとかはあんまり
適当でさいい意味でねお家での本っていう
この日常を
撮ったりしてたけど最近彼らも変わろうと
思ってて
スケジュールくんでしっかり撮影に行くん
よ遠くに行ったりとかキャンプ場を借り
たりとか海に行ったりとか山行ったりとか
余計入れるやつがなくなったっていう
そっかそうだねもちろんいいことよ頑張っ
てだからそこを俺に合わせて我慢されるの
も嫌だし彼らが考えてみんなで話し合って
目指してる方向だったら俺はそれでいいの
かなと思っておりますいや
納得させてもらいましたただそこにはじめ
しゃちょーの畑のはじめしゃちょーという
ものがあるのに違和感は感じるそうだよね
今野畑
メインチャンネルが多いよそうだねはい
キングでも好き勝手やらせてもらってし
たいことを実現するためにみんなに頑張っ
ていただきたいっていうチャンネルなん
ですけど
畑に関してはもちろん俺の要望とかこう
あったらいいなっていうとこもあるけど
どっちかというとみんながどう当てたいか
とかどうしたいかにも
みんなでいいように
進んでくれればいいなっていうのが社長と
しての気持ちっていうことですね
間違いないです」っていう感じですね私
から
畑に関してはありがとうございますま最後
にまたあるま一応
聞きたいなって今ちょっと聞いちゃった
けど
将来展望ってなんか預からない僕の将来
展望ですね
えーズバリ寄せていただきますないです
ありがとうございましたいやマジで言うと
サウナ
屋さんやりたいぐらいサムネさんやりたい
今はちょうどサウナは作り始めたそうです
ねはい
逆に聞きたいんですけども
畑どうすべきだと思いますかどうすべき
いやもちろんまだ3ヶ月ちょっとしか経っ
てなくて
先輩
自分が言っていいのかというか口出しする
ようなことではないかなっていうところ
いやもう1社員として意見はお聞きしたい
ところではあります
現状兄貴が出れないっていうのは
正直もうどうしようもないっていうところ
が
忙しすぎてっていうのと形が変わってき
てっていうのがあって
皆さんがすごいこう頑張ってこう
チャンネルを盛り上げてもらえるように
環境整備をとかうちの会社やっていくって
いうのが大事なのかななるほどね思います
それに関して最近色々見直すべき点があっ
てジムの話だからあんまりみんな言うべき
ことじゃないんだけど
色々話し合ってはいるあとは
企画とかが作ると結局兄貴ってそれ
ぶっ飛んだ頭をしてる
部分がいやいや僕普通の人ですか無理です
あれの人ではございませんあそうですか
普通の人は休日は週に2日通ってるだから
そういうところである程度兄貴が後はSで
もないけど一緒に
企画は作れたりとかっていうのができたら
いいのかなっていう気も
俺最近ね言ったよの時にもう何としても
出るためにどうすればいいか考えた時
週に1回でいいから
誰か1人うちを起こしてもう24時間俺に
密着しろって
そしたら強制でも俺と何かが取れるから
そうでもしないと俺関われないなと思って
こうやってなった時点でさ畑の人たちと
兄貴で
多少やっぱりこう今までとかって距離が
できたんですよね
てる人で生活してたりしてたタイミングと
は今ちょっと違う状態になってるけどそう
いうのはできる限りコミュニケーションの
密接にとって
った時も強制的に一緒に動画を撮るしか
ない気がするねチャンネル名どうする
チャンネル名の畑でいやはじめしゃで
かっこつけよあーなるほどねなるほどね
あーそれはちょっとあげたなこればかりは
さマジで俺難しいと思ったんだけど
グループチャンネルじゃん一応別に俺は
その通りないんですけどね俺はいろんな人
が
入ったり出たりいや俺も覚えてるよ畑じゃ
ない人がいるっていうのをやりたかったん
だけど
気づいたらグループチャンネルになってま
すっていやだってファンの方々が
いらっしゃるとかやる場所が始め社長の畑
だったらここの人気をつけたいとかそれと
も賑やかにしたいっていうのは思うという
か
すぐにずっと出るのって多分難しいよね
グループチャンネルの難しさというかやっ
たことなかったから全く知らなくて気づい
たらグループチャンネル化しててグループ
チャンネルの
視聴者さんとかファンって
めちゃくちゃ気持ち強いなっていうのが
思ったあー
惜しいみたいなよくも悪くもねなるほどね
自分でそのメンバーが
罰ゲームとかで苦しそうだったらやっぱ
可哀想って人一倍思うしなんかね熱量が
すごいなっていうなるほどね感じて俺は
その熱量に負けて自分がやりたいですって
いうことをすぐ
言えにくくなったなんか自分が畑をこうし
たいですって言っても俺以外のメンバーの
視聴者さんとかパンとかが
ね一体多数になってる
メインはさもう俺の自由じゃん
水着の女の子集めようと何しても大丈夫
やっぱ俺以外の人を応援してる人からする
と俺の一声で色々変わるのがすごい言い
づらくなったなって
お宝見たら食券内容でいやそうなんですよ
パワハラみたいになっちゃうんですよいい
んじゃないかなって思う
べきことを畑にもさせてあげたいけどそれ
を応援する人がいるんな人がいて色んな
思いがあまりに
頼すぎてちょっとね俺は使いづらいなって
思ったねそうだね兄貴の意見をズバって
通しちゃうと思うまあその人たちが
同意してたとしても
周りから見たら何がする
裏でやってんじゃないかみたいないやむず
いなー
むじいよ
みんなで撮るチャンネルってそれはね3
ヶ月ちょっといて
やっぱりこう動画外とかで
ちょくちょく聞いたりしてたけどいや
難しいよなっていうのが正直な感じですね
これをこうすればいいっていうのが
もちろんあるわけではないで何かしらを
決めてやっていきながらのことだから
難しいよね
畑入る
畑
ちょっと考えさせてもらって分かりますか
いやーなかなか悩んではいるけども時間
そこに咲けないなっていう問題に切り込ん
できたねあなた見てる人たちも
気になる部分ではあるのかな間違いない
ですよこれからも悩みながら
健やかに頑張ってくださいね
[笑い]
[音楽]
聞きたいことがあるんですけども
逆に3ヶ月ぐらい
多治見社長の元で働いてみてどうでした
俺がどうこうじゃなくてこの1
普通に働いてた人から見てはじめしゃ
ちょーについてくる
動きというかこのお仕事ってどんな感じ
でしたあーいやまず思ったのは1つのこと
をやり続けるっていう仕事じゃなくて
突然動画の編集してほしい
荷物を持ってきてほしいとか時間も結構
めちゃめちゃ当たりにねちょっと東京に
荷物忘れたから持ってきてたかも仕事に
なってるのでは俺のミスそうだねだから
いろんなことを
ができて
楽しいなっていうところとそれは何よりだ
大変だ
注意するでしょう
本当にそれは皆さんにちゃんとダメな
ところはダメって俺以外の注意してる
ちょっとくれてるしてくれてる人も
いろいろそれはいい環境だよ
楽しいと
忙しい
頑張りたいという感じかななるほどね
不思議でしょこんな仕事
不思議になります同じ仕事基本的に二度と
来ないからね
同じ動画の編集も二度とないしこの動画も
さ
二度と撮るわけないじゃんそうだ
全く同じことはないから絶対なんか一番
物作りってルーティーンからかけ離れてる
気がしてて太陽力めっちゃつくと思うよね
もちろん同じことの繰り返して仕事って
なかなかないと思うけどそれでもやけに
変わった仕事かなって思ってでも楽しん
でるんだったら全然俺的には良かったです
休憩時間の昼ご飯とかに動画も回ってない
のに1万円分4人とかで食べようとかいう
怖い怖い怖い誰だろう
でなんかこう自分で負けてキング牛丼
食べることになったり俺だね
[音楽]